highest score the night how are you guys
feeling I'm feeling really great I I
felt good about well you took my last
week well let me tell you about that
you're amazing you are not natural you
are not natural I think I'm never gonna
talk again felt so happy and you were
dancing to Taylor Swift I know a swifty
was really feeling it and I maybe that's
why I I feel like I did good Colton was
here and Chris Harrison was I know it
was so cool out well it's good not good
she just told me what happened during
the dance you're just like perform but
don't really see in the audience I made
direct eye contact with Chris Harrison
when I do this like that move and I was
oh my gosh
but in rigor yeah but it was really good
to see all the support that I have been
getting from bachelor nation and my
people upset Carrie Ann Inaba was just
here she said that you and James are the
front-runners this season how does that
make you feel it's I mean that feels
really great but there's still hopefully
a lot left of the season ago so I just
want to keep improving improving and I
think James is amazing
I mean I'm giving you all the credit in
the world but James is like wow James
incredible we usually watch each other's
dance we do shows with with James and
Emma we bug them a lot so sad when one
of you has to win and one of you has to
lose well you know what as long as we
make it to the end together it's a
journey
[Music]